[Aplausos]
[Música]
ya es oficial el 20 de enero de 2017
donald trump se convierte en el 45º
presidente de los eeuu el hombre más
poderoso de la tierra en visual política
que hemos sacado montones de vídeos
explicando todos los despropósitos de su
programa electoral pero la pregunta que
nos hacemos hoy es hasta qué punto tiene
poder para llevarlos a cabo y el poder
real tiene el presidente de los eeuu
[Música]
por ejemplo si gana el trump se levanta
una mañana y le apetece mandar todos
cabezas nucleares a cualquier otro país
puede hacerlo o tiene que consultar
previamente al congreso es posible que
el senado o la corte suprema- frenen
esas deportaciones masivas de
inmigrantes que proponía durante su
campaña electoral no olvidéis que eeuu
presume de tener una democracia
extremadamente sana donde la separación
entre poderes legislativo ejecutivo y
judicial está bien definida este sistema
que los politólogos llaman sistema de
contrapesos sirve para evitar que algún
día un psicópata tomara el control del
país e hiciera cualquier barbaridad
aprovechando el poder que ha conseguido
en las urnas
[Música]
sin embargo y aún con eso el presidente
de los eeuu y de poder para hacer un
montón de cosas por su cuenta y creedme
algunas de ellas os van a dar mucho
miedo hoy vamos a ver todo lo que puede
hacer donald trump sin necesidad de
consultarlo con nadie y lo vamos a hacer
junto con mi amigo sanders sneijder
sanders es uno de los coautores de
reconsiderar media uno de los mejores
podcasts políticos que hay en eeuu
hola fonseca y un fuerte abrazo a todos
los suscriptores de visual político
existe el botón nuclear la respuesta es
sí el botón nuclear también conocido
como fútbol nuclear o botón del fin del
mundo existe y se guarda en este maletín
que veis en la foto
[Música]
y como su propio nombre indica es una
consola con un botón cuando el
presidente presiona ese botón
automáticamente manda una orden a dos
oficiales del ejército estadounidense
normalmente dos tenientes que están en
uno de los aviones bombarderos que
albergan una bomba nuclear
esos dos oficiales tienen una llave cada
uno si esas dos llaves se meten en sus
respectivas cerraduras a la vez se abre
la compuerta y se lanza una bomba
nuclear
y os preguntaréis existe alguna ley
especial o algún tipo de reglamento para
poder lanzar esa bomba pues no no hace
falta tal cual
[Música]
desde el punto de vista legal y
constitucional un presidente puede
presionar el botón en cualquier momento
y físicamente el personal militar tiene
que llevar a cabo la orden y si le
ignoran se considera en subordinación y
podrían destituir les o someterles a la
ley marcial todo esto viene de la tierra
fría el gobierno de los eeuu se sentía
amenazado por la unión soviética que
podría lanzar una bomba nuclear en
cualquier momento en ese caso la casa
blanca tendría que reaccionar al momento
y no habría tiempo para tener que
debatirlo en el congreso ni en el senado
cómo
[Música]
por cierto que esto tan bonito que está
sonando es la música de know we spain un
grupo de nu metal de lima en perú que
nos ha enviado su música si os gusta
encontrareis más información sobre ellos
en los enlaces de la descripción
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque todavía
hay más imaginad que un día
donald trump se levanta y como le caen
mal los chinos deciden lanzar un par de
cabezas nucleares contra beijing pues si
legalmente puede hacerlo pero no se
saldría de rositas
concretamente bombardear china hoy en
día violaría el derecho internacional y
todos los acuerdos de alianza que hay
entre china y eeuu eso significa que el
congreso de los eeuu tendría que
exigirle explicaciones e incluso hacer
una votación para elegir si habría que
echarle o mantenerle en el poder a este
proceso se le conoce con el nombre de
impeachment y no es la primera vez que
se realiza y si no que se lo pregunten
al bueno de richard nixon
pero ojo porque no solamente vamos a
hablar de bombas atómicas qué pasa con
las guerras puede donald trump
declararle la guerra a otro país vamos a
verlo
[Música]
tierra y estado de emergencia para
declararle una guerra oficialmente a
otro país hace falta una votación en el
congreso así que no
donald trump no puede declarar una
guerra por su propia cuenta y riesgo
pero sin embargo en casos de emergencia
el presidente puede enviar tropas a un
país aunque no se haya declarado una
guerra oficialmente aquí tenéis un
ejemplo
[Música]
obama recibe críticas de los dos
partidos políticos por no haber pedido
autorización al congreso antes de
ordenar al ejército americano que se
uniera a los ataques contra el gobierno
de libia es decir que si donald trump
quisiera podría mandar tropas a irán por
ejemplo pero sólo podría hacerlo durante
60 días después de esos dos meses
tendría que ir al congreso pedir una
aprobación y someter a votación la
declaración oficial de guerra para poder
prolongar la presencia militar en la
zona dicho de otra manera donald trump
podría mandar tropas a otro país pero si
quiere que se queden más de 60 días
necesita someter la votación en el
congreso pero una vez el congreso ha
aprobado la guerra el presidente vuelve
a tener el poder para controlar todos
los aspectos de la guerra
y eso significa que el presidente puede
ordenar operaciones muy concretas
acordaos de la captura de osama bin
laden que fue dirigida directamente por
el presidente obama o incluso los
bombardeos de drones que también
autorizó nuestro querido amigo barack
pero si todo esto os parece poco
esperado un momento porque ahora vamos a
hablar de la economía
adiós a los tratados de libre comercio
en lo que respecta a la economía
prácticamente todas las decisiones de
política doméstica tienen que pasar por
el congreso sí donald trump quisiera
subir o bajar los impuestos tendría que
someterlo a votación parlamentaria lo
mismo ocurriría si quisiera liberalizar
un sector o nacionalizar una empresa en
muchos casos incluso tendría que
enfrentarse al tribunal supremo oa los
propios gobiernos de los estados pero de
eso vamos a hablar en otro vídeo lo
cierto es que donde sí tiene poder
donald trump es para hacer y deshacer
los acuerdos de libre comercio
internacional y no os penséis que es
ninguna tontería porque las empresas de
eeuu compran y venden cosas en todo el
mundo y estas relaciones comerciales se
regulan a través de tratados entre
países
[Música]
y muchos gobiernos ponen impuestos
especiales que se llaman aranceles a los
productos que vienen de países
extranjeros para evitar esto las
naciones suelen firmar lo que llaman
tratados de libre comercio en
norteamérica tenemos un tratado que se
llama el nafta que permite el comercio
sin impuestos entre en méxico eeuu y
canadá como este tratado se firmó así
más de 20 años
donald trump ya no puede romperlo o al
menos necesita hacerlo a través del
congreso y el senado sin embargo hay
otros dos grandes tratados que aprobó
obama pero que todavía tienen que
someterse a la votación del congreso
por un lado está el pp que consiste en
crear una zona de libre comercio entre
eeuu asia y el pacífico y por el otro
está el ttp que consistiría en lo mismo
pero entre eeuu y la unión europea estos
dos acuerdos ya están prácticamente
hechos y solamente falta que se voten en
el congreso pero una vez se han aprobado
los tiene que firmar el presidente de
los eeuu y si quiere puede vetar los
para cuando llegara ese momento donald
trump ya sería el jefe del estado y como
sabemos no es precisamente un gran amigo
del libre comercio
tzipi si el pp es un acuerdo horrible es
un acuerdo que no va a dar más que
problemas es un acuerdo pensado para que
china entre como hace siempre por la
puerta de atrás ahora bien sólo puede
invitar la ley o el acuerdo en su
totalidad no puede decir esta parte si
esta parte no la ley estadounidense sólo
le permite vetar una ley en su totalidad
pero sin duda alguna
a donald trump le gustará utilizar sus
nuevos superpoderes como presidente es
esta
inmigración aquí está la palabra más
odiada y a la vez más repetida de donald
trump durante su campaña electoral sin
embargo y por irónico que resulte apenas
tiene margen de actuación en este punto
para construir el muro necesitaría la
aprobación del congreso porque no deja
de ser una obra pública el único modo
por el cuadro trump podría construir el
muro por su propia cuenta sería si
consiguiera que méxico pagará por ello y
que hiciera la obra en su lado de la
frontera es decir que el muro se
levantará en territorio mexicano
[Música]
pero de eso vamos a hablar más tarde lo
cierto es que lo único que va a poder
hacer donald trump es ordenar al
departamento de seguridad nacional que
ponga las deportaciones a inmigrantes
ilegales como prioridad máxima pero
sabéis cuál es el problema
que obama ya lo ha hecho antes que él
[Música]
según datos del gobierno la
administración obama ha deportado a más
gente que ninguna administración
anterior es decir que por irónico que
resulte la administración trump en lo
que en migración ilegal se refiere va a
ser bastante continuista de la
administración obama
y la pregunta es os parece bien que el
presidente más poderoso del mundo tenga
capacidad para tomar tantísimas
decisiones de forma unilateral no os da
miedo que una única persona pueda
decidir lanzar bombas nucleares contra
otro país podéis dejar de vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y ojo que
donald trump ya ha dicho que quiere
ampliar su arsenal nuclear pero eso os
lo explicamos en este otro vídeo si
queréis echarle un vistazo haced click
aquí y no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto el mundo
una mano en la cabeza
con movimientos sexys movimientos de una
mano en la cintura una